"Леопард" готується до атаки.
Очікувалося, що ці танки мають стати вирішальними
для контрнаступу України, який триває
безперервно вже понад три місяці.
Леопард – це хижак.
А оскільки ми працюємо вночі, то нічний хижак.
Артем - водій і механік танка. Мобілізований рік тому,
він починав воювати на старому радянському танку.
На противагу якому "Леопард", каже військовий, має багато переваг.
У нього є швидкість, тобто внаслідок цього я знаю,
що в екстремальній ситуації я зможу швидко зробити свою роботу,
швидко відійти, якщо потрібно, швидко під’їхати.
Тобто в цьому перевага цього танка, якщо порівнювати
з нашими танками. Якщо по нам ведеться вогонь,
ми це бачимо, нас це докладають, то перевага цієї машини,
що ми можемо швидко переміщуватися на ній.
Це велика перевага.
Вони не тільки швидкі. "Леопарди", розвиваючи швидкість
понад 70 кілометрів за годину, ще й оснащені приладами
нічного бачення та оптикою, чим значно перевершують ворожі.
Командир Ігор розповідає нам, що "Леопарди"
з його роти знищили набагато більше ворожих танків,
ніж могли з тими, що були раніше.
Але росіяни встигли пристосуватися до цього.
Саме "Леопарди" зараз роблять дуже хороший вогневий вал
і дуже допомагають цим піхоті для подальшого
просування сухопутних сил.
Дивіться, як було на початку наступу: росіяни дуже викочували
на заподію нам свої танки. Оскільки "Леопарди"
майже всіх їх нищили – вони перестали це робити.
Вони дуже мало викочують свою техніку, вони бояться "Леопардів".
Вони з "Леопардами" борються іншими засобами.
Тепер вони використовують безпілотники.
Міністерство оборони Росії стверджує, що це відео,
зняте на початку цього літа, показує атаку на український танк
за допомогою безпілотника "Ланцет".
Українці кажуть, що "Леопарди" зарекомендували себе
на полі бою. Вони швидші, можуть стріляти далі
і безпечніші за екіпажі танків радянської конструкції,
які були до цього. Але, здається, вони створюють проблеми,
коли справа стосується технічного обслуговування
та особливо ремонту.
Артем і його команда можуть виконувати певні ремонтні
роботи на місці. Проте каже, що часто їм потрібен
ремонт гусениць танка.
Найчастіше в нас йдуть під заміну гумки,
вони дуже швидко зношуються. І катки.
Гума дуже швидко відлітає. Часто нам доводиться
замінювати катки, замовляти нові.
Технічне обслуговування - це одне, а от усунення пошкоджень
- набагато серйозніше. Складніші пошкодження
доводиться усувати на заводах за межами України.
Один із таких запрацював на території Польщі.
Це завод "Бумар-Лабенди" у Гливицях, де відкрили центр
технічного обслуговування та ремонту отриманих
Україною танків Leopard 2 A4.
Ми на початку цієї дороги. Йдеться про ремонт і перевірку танків
для української армії. Наразі ми прийняли 5 таких танків.
Ми на етапі завершення ремонту та перевірки перших двох.
І це поки що початок цього шляху.
Спочатку танки проходять повний огляд, далі їх ремонтують,
а після ремонту - відправляють тестувати на полігонах.
Лише після цього "Леопарди" відправляють назад в Україну.
Вони вже на завершальній стадії підготовки до покриття
та підготовки танка до випробувань перед передачею замовнику.
Якщо ми трохи посунемося в цьому напрямку,
ми побачимо інші машини, які все ще перебувають на перевірці,
це там, де машини все ще накриті, там вежа та шасі
все ще на перевірці.
Ці танки брали участь у бойових діях в Україні
під час повномасштабного вторгнення.
Тому мають ряд проблем, кажуть працівники.
Починаючи від проблем з гарматами, які ми бачимо з іншого боку.
Так само і тут: двигун пішов на перевірку та доопрацювання
- щоб усунути витікання.
Що стосується питань ремонту шасі, то тут також йде
завершення повного капітального ремонту Leopard 2 A4.
Перевіряємо пускові установки димових гранатометів.
Українці, мабуть, користуються ними щодня
і вони вже врятували життя не одній людині.
І стволи, які зношуються через різного роду боєприпаси,
якими стріляють українці.
Такі ремонти за межами України можуть вивести
танк з бойових дій на місяці.
Інша проблема - броня.
У Леопарда 2 А4 вона легша, ніж у радянських бойових танків.
Величезні мінні поля, встановлені росіянами,
уповільнюють контрнаступ.
Ці військові відчули це на власному досвіді.
На одному танку ми вже підірвалися на міні.
У нас контужений екіпаж уже.
Ми його відремонтували після того, як були в лікарні,
відремонтували, поміняли все, що треба.
Тому військові сподіваються в майбутньому отримати
танки з кращою бронею. Незабаром вони повернуться на передову,
щоб ночами знову захищати від ворога.